we're in a period of transition and
transitions always hard and there's this
dilemma between sort of paid directly
versus indirectly I grew up with free
television now it wasn't free there were
these commercials and so the economic
model was driven through commercials and
through advertising that same model in
fact is what drives google and google
has a very powerful and new advertising
model that for them prints money some of
the other media companies and I call
Google the media company because they
really are one charge more directly now
whether it's through a combination of
advertising and subscription they there
is a much more direct in the sense that
there's a subscription piece and people
would like their customers to pay I'm
not against paying at all what I'm
against is the complexity of pain and
you very often go to a website you try
to click on something and sometimes
they'll even say it's free but they have
to fill out this form and I'd much
prefer to pay and not fill out the form
I mean the time is is to me far more
inconvenient than and paying for it and
I think that will see a world that will
get easier to use and a lot more
information will be free a lot of people
will contribute the notion of collective
contribution like the Wikipedia it's a
very powerful one it's not the only one
but it's a powerful one and so will see
that grow
you